in debt to the government it's a shared
reality for many of Britain's poorest
families
their benefits are being quietly docked
to recoup historic overpayments that in
some cases were paid to them by mistake
is the letter that hmrc has sent me
Michelle is among them she is losing 20
pounds a month from her Universal Credit
after being overpaid child tax credit
several years ago it's an injustice I
feel like it's an injustice hmrc failed
to update their records after she told
them she had been hospitalized and
therefore no longer able to care for her
children hmrc claims she didn't she has
been battling with them ever since she
was like I'm hitting my head against a
brick wall what impact has this whole
process had on your well-being I'm just
you know living
day by day I can't save you know I can't
go out I just feel like I'm not getting
anywhere I'm not getting anywhere fast
figures obtained by Sky News show that
1.3 million Universal Credit claimants
had payment deductions last year because
of historic tax credit overpayments it's
a number that's on the rise in total
372.5 million pounds was deducted from
claimants cases like these are playing
out across the country and while hmrc
maintains that the vast majority are
down to the claimant's own error or
fraud
people are also clearly being blamed for
hmrc's own mistakes
and the whole process is causing
destitution and distress
Vicky said she informed hmrc she no
longer needed tax credits her payment
stopped but the agency maintains she was
overpaid and even blamed it on a
computer glitch I felt completely
helpless I got off the phone and I was
in absolute floods of Tears because I
just felt like
this is so unfair like why why have I
got to pay this money because of a
computer glitch and there was literally
nothing that I can do about it and they
didn't seem to care at all Weeks Later
Vicky received a call from a debt
collection agency she is now on a
payment plan for the next seven years
almost 29 000 cases like these are being
handled by private debt collection
agencies
at food banks Frontline workers told us
that the vast majority of visitors are
in debt to the government MP said
deductions should be paused immediately
while the cost of living crisis is
Raging people are completely unaware of
these debts when suddenly money starts
getting taken out of their Universal
Credit monthly payments the government
should pause these deductions while
inflation is running at its current
level unfortunately the government
rejected that recommendation
after Sky News took her case to hmrc it
apologized to Michelle and has written
off her debts
it says that Vicky also did nothing
wrong but maintains that she does owe
the money it apologized for failing to
explain the debt to her
for both of these women and many others
the process of challenging deductions
has left them feeling belittled ashamed
and ignored
Sky News